I really did try to take you down those
hilarious yeah ruin the party yeah you
sprawled on me and my ear was red fur
just stop it just stop being same event
I cried for Tim Kennedy I think you know
what I think
try taking out drugs did we do drugs
then yeah we did we did DMT was that
thing that was oh man are you sure yeah
I'm lit through I'm like why was I
crying like that that dude interesting
hold up could not stop cross so Brendan
and I did we did DMT we didn't EMT trip
we didn't know it was a gym I said I
can't believe you guys did that
do you really even know team weed I
would do a heartbeat we didn't know
which what ayahuasca is we didn't know
what to expect
I meant to psychedelics now I've never
done it but I want to do acid next
listen if you're young and listening to
this don't I'm 52 and then no deemed I
lasted I'm not I don't have a kid even
who's young okay but if you're an adult
it's up to you but he was lost
DMT so I've never I'm not a drug guy
right I never loved to drink guys never
done cocaine and not even weed right not
really a boozer so every city we find
out we're gonna we're gonna be invited
we're invited this quantum quote
ceremony by a shaman who will remain
nameless and yeah we're like oh we gotta
do this I'm not gonna push out well
really good with you jobs right so we're
like alright well here goes if I hadn't
been with you I think I would have been
a [ __ ] and I would been skinned you
smoked it it was to me
borderline life-changing Wow I'm a big
believer in trying it then we did it
again I wanted to keep doing it me too I
wanna eat like this I don't know
so we did we did so the first one it was
like I shot off into the heavens I was
surrounded by a warm gold cloud can I
got up into like this cool area the
second one is like I was in space almost
just me too and I can hear you and you
guy I heard you laughing and you sounded
like you were in another dimension you
were like oh there goes a hyena I'm
serious I was laughing so loud I'll
burgers wool wool bro chill chill I
couldn't stop laughing I'm such a grand
it was it was the most impressive
I thought I was there for three days I
asked top we got down with dude how long
was the up there he goes 30 sec why are
my pants down I know it is an incredible
thing that's right I never bought us
together I never put it together here
sobbing apart they read they stole
everything get out that's why you think
we're just doing with you guys right 11
hour old producer they wouldn't know
what you can do with these guys right
you leave then the next day we have the
party I'm like dude I'm an emotional
dude I cried like I cried when I shot my
special I cried was like I'm central I
cried when I bought my Raptor so the
thing is is oh so the next day like I'm
not that big of a emotional Randolph
with Tim Kennedy like we did the party
that's a pocket throw and we love them
and he goes I'm just worried about him I
don't want him to die he's a great guy
go do huh oh hold on I'm talking
waterworks like I've never cried so hard
in my life I'm talking to my wife and
I'm talking on the phone I've sunglass
son and I'm talking about him I'm like
this I go like this I go yeah yeah so
that's good yeah all right now but then
I'll talk to you in there
like my dog hey bro you want a towel or
you wanna hold ya know I'll see you soon
baby he goes yet and the thing ya know
I'll be home and then he goes are you
serious right now and I'm like yeah is
again he goes hold on he's crying let me
call you back here dude are you [ __ ]
I'm talking snot I have to go into the
party and leave him in the car I tell
Brian don't tell everyone that I'm in
here crying me a few to get my [ __ ]
together yeah tell him I have allergies
to I walk in the player was like crying
I go Jews all right guys
Brendan Vissarion is weeping in my car
doesn't make sense though 100% yeah cuz
there's 100 per day night I love Tim
Kings my favorite people on earth I'll
do anything for that man but I wouldn't
cry like that that's so interesting
because we had such a great row that is
residue so interesting that's so
interesting
it affected you that deeply that makes
no I put like two weeks on Bazar does
that ever happen to you yeah I'll wake
up at like 3:00 or 4:00 in the morning
and a bit I've been working on something
well trigger and let's do dare it is yes
then the same thing I don't know why it
came to me as I dude the reason you were
crying cuz you're on DMT I'm like holy
[ __ ] that happened four years ago yeah
yes am i dead except TNT was fun
it's incredible dude we should I knew it
with more chicks we should all thank you
well that's what ayahuasca those trips
is like all these guys were like what's
gonna that's good approve if you look
around it's like just one hot
20-something after another in like some
summer turns shaman like okay hey hey
guys how's this spiritual journey gone
this is an excuse to bang no no you
smoke this ayahuasca man suck in the
wrong guy every guy it's all one big
excuse to bang it's a guys fight bulls
cuz they want chicks - life is coming up
maybe we should do a little DMT with our
brain get weird let me show you DMT and
we're math and freak each other you know
it did just man saying and then
reviewing my you face stop talking about
you know you talk come and get you can't
stop talking about suck in relieving
tension now and now you the giant wants
me to wear a mask and you are asked and
you want to do DMT it's my firt and
you're looking at me like a hawk it's in
my beret Anita it's the blue I'm not
infertile a guy on guy it's love no no I
said that's what you would not ask we
invite a bunch of I don't know dude
because you you you my birthday
picture this I'm Batman kind of I'm not
going anywhere near you when you're on
DMT full of love and a mask on the same
eyes wide shut
you don't want Olsen I'll get there in
Gua we're all the girls ah they couldn't
make it there Uber's I happen to me one
time let's have a guy's house a very
rich doctor he had a strop not Molly
both the other thing with what's the
thing diem doesn't like MDMA MDMA that
his mom yet he had Rasta Seawatch in
Bali and he goes dude this is a while
ago we're all in the hot tub my
brother's there Cody all fighters
Network ton of big spiders
studs we all drop Molly a ton of it is
girls are coming by the truckload it's
like sweet we're all [ __ ] shredded
this is this is a doctor friend doctor
yeah and we're all we always had we're
suspect that he liked guys are all young
lion taking lions raging raging yeah
yeah in the hot tub we're all sitting
around and funder my brother goes we're
all high as [ __ ] - yo my brother guess
he's gay guy goes where's the chicks at
we're all high were like yeah where are
all the girls and then he goes they
should be here man I'll know when they
come in he goes but they don't show I
mean he goes like this who the doctor
goes but they don't show Wow my brother
he goes no [ __ ] does that mean
it's called a claptrap that's called a
[ __ ] dude you're Carly's car where no
girl showed up he's got one girl showed
up whips full of dongs now yeah one
female showed up yeah that guy's clearly
talking to you why wouldn't I give that
to you as it's a gift it's a gift it's a
gift